bonjour
qui parmi vous a déjà vu sur internet
une vidéo d'animaux qui font des choses
complètement folles
par exemple un chat et une chouette qui
passent leur temps à s'amuser ensemble
un gnou qui se fait attaquer par un
crocodile et il ya deux hippopotames qui
arrivent et qui le sauva ou des
histoires d'amitié un peu folle comme un
ours et un tigre etc
c'est fou non ça fait des centaines de
millions de vu et on trouve ça fou la
question c'est pourquoi est ce qu'on
trouve ça fou et en fait on a l'habitude
de concevoir la nature comme un ensemble
d'espèces bien déterminée qui font des
comportements voilà qui ont des gènes et
et tout est bien rangé bien ordonnée et
en fait tous ces animaux et ces plantes
évolue dans une nature avec des
relations de prédation de chaîne
alimentaire de compétition d'agression
etc
darwin parlait de la sélection des plus
aptes et puis des philosophes ont
transformé ces propos on parlait de loi
du plus fort ou de loi de la jungle
il ya une quinzaine d'années en fait je
travaillais dans la jungle justement
c'était en guyane et j'ai étudié le
comportement des fourmis j'ai fait
quelques années de recherches et j'ai
effectivement vu des fourmis qui qui
capturait des proies ici une mouche elle
le faisait en coopérant et puis j'ai vu
aussi des fourmis qui s'associe à des
arbres ici à une plante en particulier
qui produit un exode à sucrer sur des
nectaire extra fleurot les fourmis cette
fourmi cette espèce vient s'en abreuver
et en échange offre un peu de protection
à l'arbre contre des insectes ravageurs
nourriture contre protection et puis
cette fourmi elle fait des nids en
carton sous les feuilles
c'est une fourmis arboricoles et on
s'est rendu compte avec les collègues
chercheurs qui avaient des
des coccinelles qui vivait en étroite
association danser ni avec les fourmis
c'est bizarre les coccinelles et les
fourmis d'habitude et puis a même des
guêpes des toutes petites guêpes qui
font leur nid dans les nids de fourmis
en association étroite aussi alors
finalement quoi dans la jungle qu'est ce
qui se passe est en fait je me suis
intéressé en parallèle de ma thèse
pendant des années à tout ce qui se
passait dans le monde animal et puis
j'ai étendu mais mes lectures disons au
monde végétal aux champignons aussi aux
micro organismes
je suis allé voir ce que faisait ce que
faisait les humains en économie en
psychologie en politique et en
neuroscience et j'ai vécu enfin j'ai
vécu des grands déclic ça a changé ma
vision du monde ma manière de voir les
autres êtres vivants et cc déclic je
voulais partager avec vous aujourd'hui
on va faire un petit tour dans la jungle
et on connaît les fourmis les fourmis
c'est une famille ils s'entraident et
les biologistes parle d'altruisme qu'en
inde est une des fourmis mais ça peut
être des abeilles des termites il ya
beaucoup de sociétés animales qui vivent
en colonies en famille et un des
individus se sacrifie pour ses
congénères par l'altruisme ya pas de
connotation morale c'est comme ça qu'ils
appellent ils appellent ces
comportements et puis ça peut être aussi
au sein d'une espèce mais entre
individus non apparentés il ya plus de
familles mais on s'associe alors on
parle plus de coopération pour ici ce
sont des pigeons qui échappent plus
facilement aux prédateurs en s'associant
en coopérant mais ça peut être des loups
qui chassent en meute et ses milliers
d'exemples et puis il ya des
associations entre espèces ici en fait
la pollinisation et ben c'est une une
sorte d'association à bénéfice mutuel
entre la plante qui fournit du lait
liquide sucré en échange de la
dispersion du déplacement de ses gamètes
du pollen transports contre nourriture
et là aussi il ya des milliers
d'exemples et en tanzanie au kenya il ya
aussi des associations par exemple dans
les grandes migrations
il ya des milliers d'un des millions
d'individus mêmes qui sont concernés dès
que nous qui s'associe à des zèbres et à
des gazelles et les zèbres en fait c'est
un peu le gps ce que les gnous ils sont
forts sur l'odorat et les zèbres il voit
plus loin et les gazelles elles
entendent mieux l'ensemble ça va mieux
c'est plus efficace et dans le dans la
forêt eh ben c'est aussi fou parce que
ça fait quelques années que les
scientifiques découvrent des choses
incroyables
par exemple on commence à savoir
maintenant assez bien et l'idée
popularisé que les racines des arbres se
prolonge par des champignons des
mycorhizes qui permettent à l'arbre
d'aller plus profond plus loin capturer
l'eau prendre les nutriments et en
échange
l'arbre qui photo synthétise offre des
sucres aux champignons on a une symbiose
très très efficace qui est très répandu
mais le champignon il est malin parce
qu'en fait dans la forêt il a fait un
grand réseau qui interconnecte toutes
les racines des plantes et des arbres
si bien que les arbres entre eux peuvent
s'associer c'est à dire se transmettent
des nutriments via le mic les mycorhizes
et les arbres en meilleure santé qui
captent plus de sucre ils vont pouvoir
offrir enfin offrir donner des sucs
transférer des sucres aux individus les
jeunes qui sont en pleine croissance où
les malades ou ceux qui ont du mal ou
ceux qui sont plus à l'ombre et qui en
ont besoin et ce qui est fou c'est que
ça arrive aussi entre espèces
différentes
un boulot peut transférer des sucres un
sapin et inversement
en fait ce qu'on se rend compte et c'est
que les arbres ça fait ont inventé
depuis des millions d'années
les allocations familiales et la
sécurité sociale les millions d'années
avant nous je reprends l'expression du
biologiste gauthier chapelle avec qui
j'ai écrit ce livre sur l'entr'aide et
chez l'humain alors mais chez l'humain
il ya une diversité de manière de
s'entraider de s'associer qui implique
c'est très complexe qui implique des
sentiments aussi divers que l'amitié
l'amour la confiance le sentiment
d'équité
le sentiment de sécurité la réputation
et ses traits à pas rentrer dans les
détails maintenant juste vous voulez
vous dire sur l'humain le choeur de
l'entr'aide chez les humains et c'est
très puissant c'est l'empathie c'est
cette capacité qu'on a très profondément
ancré en nous de se mettre à la place de
l'autre de ressentir ce que ressent
l'autre en nous ce que ressent l'autre
il est en nous et ça c'est quelque chose
qui arrive très tôt pain on est on est
câblé pour ça il ya des expériences
magnifique sur les bébés dès 9 mois à 7
mois qui développent des comportements
déjà qu'ils montrent déjà des
comportements pro sociaux avant même
d'avoir acquis le langage ou la raison
etc
et puis chez nos cousins les primates
aussi des comportements très semblable
avec beaucoup d'empathie et herat est en
fait l'empathie ça fait un jeu de
miroirs à l'infini qui permet de rentrer
dans un cercle dans une relation de
réciprocité
c'est ça le coeur de l'entr'aide chez
l'être humain et l'être humain
il a cette capacité exceptionnelle à
étendre la réciprocité au delà des
petits groupes
parce que la réciprocité ça existait
beaucoup d'espèces mais chez l'humain on
peut l'étendre grâce à des contrats des
normes sociales des institutions à des
groupes extrêmement large extrêmement
grand de plusieurs milliers millions
d'individus
ce qui fait que nous sommes devenus une
espèce ultra sociale et c'est unique
dans le nom dans le monde vivant on peut
coopérer entre millions d'individus
même entre personnes qui se connaissent
pas entre personnes anonymes et c'est
alors dans la jungle c'est quoi ces
déclic est bien avec gauthier ce qui
nous a marqués est-ce qui a changé notre
manière de voir le monde sait que
l'entr'aide en fait les manières de
s'associer les manières qu'ont les êtres
vivants de s'associer sont l'entraidé
partout partout et tout le temps et
depuis la nuit des temps
en fait c'est une des grandes matrice de
la jungle
c'est ce qu'on a appelé l'autre loi de
la jungle mais il suffit de s'en rendre
compte
il suffit d'y croire il suffit de le
voir et de le comprendre et il ya
quelque chose d'autre qui nous a frappés
c'est qu'il ya en fait plein de manières
de s'associer les êtres vivants ont
développé plein de couleurs plein de
deux manières différentes
voilà deux c'est une sorte de mosaïque
de toutes les couleurs c'est ce qu'on a
appelé la symbiose diversité la
biodiversité des manières d'être
ensemble et de s'associer et ça foisonne
dans la jungle et il ya une dernière une
dernière chose qui paraît fondamentale
et qui est aussi un grand déclic c'est
lui en fait c'est pas forcément les plus
forts qui survivent dans la jungle
ça peut mais c'est pas forcément les
plus forts ce sont ceux qui coopère le
plus et il ya mieux
dans les années 90 des chercheurs dans
les rocheuses dans les montagnes aux
états unis dirigée par une équipe dite
des colloques dirigé par hagan callaway
mais ils ont fait des découvertes assez
étonnante
en fait au fond de la vallée ils ont ils
ont montré qu'ils avaient une
coexistence entre pins et sapins et
lorsqu on enlevait les pins les sapins
se portait lieu ça veut dire qu'il y
avait compétition entre d'accord jusque
là rien d'étonnant mais ils sont allés
en haut de la montagne là où les
conditions sont plus difficiles en fond
de vallée
il fait chaud il ya beaucoup de
nutriments et c'est en haut de la
montagne
il fait froid il ya des conditions plus
difficiles plus en plus hostile - de
nutriments et ya toujours la coexistence
entre pins et sapins sauf que quand on
enlève un pain les sapins pousse moins
bien c'est à dire que pour les mêmes
espèces même association
quand le climat quand le milieu devient
plus hostiles l'entr'aide émergent
c'est fou il ya une formidable
expérience qui a été fait en 2016 par
des chercheurs aux pays bas ils ont pris
deux souches de levure et chaque le vus
de souche étaient transformés pouvait
pas produire un certain type d'acides
aminés deux types d'acides aminés
différents et les chercheurs ont mis ces
deux souches dans un bain avec les deux
acides aminés un bain très riche en
nutriments en acides aminés
ce qu'ils ont observé c'est que les deux
souches ont commencé à entrer en
compétition
et finalement il y en a une qui a tué
l'autre est en fait en mettant les deux
souches et en appauvrissant le milieu en
acides aminés et chercheurs ce rendu
compte que la compétition va diminuer
s'arrêtait et puis en appauvrissant
encore le milieu les deux souches se
sont mis à s'associer à coopérer à
s'entraider
pourquoi parce que l'une s'est mis à
produire les acides aminés de l'autre et
puis en appauvrissant encore le milieu
milieu très pauvre en acides aminés et
bien les deux souches sont retrouvés
dans une association obligatoire sorte
de symbiose oullins ne pouvait plus
vivre sans l'autre
c'est fou et c'est ce qui se passe chez
les manchots par exemple mais aussi des
milliers d'exemples quand les conditions
sont difficiles
là il peut y avoir des vents à moins de
100 degrés en ressenti si les manchots
étaient en compétition chacun pour soi
ils seraient tous morts déjà chez l'être
humain
il ya quelque chose de semblable des
spécialistes de psychologues sociologues
qui ont étudié les catastrophes les
tsunamis les attaques terroristes ici
c'est dans le world trade center le en
les crashs d'avion les incendies les
tremblements de terre et était à tous
les dix les discours les témoignages des
rescapés convergent
il n'y a jamais de panique ou très très
très rarement dans des conditions
spéciales
il y a plus on va à l'épicentre de la
catastrophe du phénomène plus il ya de
calme d'auto-organisation de l'entraidé
des comportements altruisme attriste
extrême et en fait même sans conditions
extraordinaires il ya des chercheurs qui
ont fait des jeux économies qu'ils ont
placé des participants voilà autour
d'une table avec chacun un peu d'argent
il devait participer à un bien commun et
il pouvait ne pas participer et les
chercheurs ont remarqué que ceux qui
participaient le plus vite qui jouait le
plus vite c'est les plus coopératifs
alors ils sont dix c'est intéressant
bon va accélérer les choses alors ils
ont demandé aux participants de jouer
plus vite plus spontanément et
globalement les gens étaient plus
coopératif plus pro sociaux et après ils
ont demandé aux gens
de prendre leur temps de réfléchir et
les gens étaient plus égoïste et en fait
l'être humain il a cette capacité
cette caractéristique plus tôt il est né
au tennis ça veut dire qu'à la naissance
on n a pas fini notre maturation onf ont
continué à grandir à croître fini notre
maturation en dehors du ventre de notre
mère
c'est à dire que à la naissance on est
extrêmement vulnérable mais extrêmement
incapable de s'en sortir et on a besoin
papa maman n'a besoin donc les tentes on
a besoin des grands parents de la grand
mère on a besoin du clan on a besoin de
la société de la culture
on a besoin de deux des autres et c'est
cette hyper ultra vulnérabilité mais qui
a fait de nous des êtres ultra sociaux
donc ultra puissant et c'est le paradoxe
de l'humain alors c'est là le grand
déclic le dernier déclic que je voulais
vous présenter
c'est comme un milieu hostile fait
émerger l'entr'aide c'est un des leçons
qu'on tire de l'observation de la jungle
c'est fou non
et vous n'y croyez toujours pas c'est
normal c'est normal parce que c'est
incroyable et c'est normal aussi parce
que l'être humain
il a cette capacité aussi d'être dans sa
tête ça fait environ soixante dix mille
ans on a passé une sorte de révolution
cognitive et on se raconte des histoires
et on est dans nos mythes dans nos
récits dans notre storytelling et on y
croit profondément parce que ça donne du
sens au monde à notre existence et on
arrive à faire des merveilles avec ça ce
qui est unique dans le monde vivant et
on arrive à aussi s'organiser pour
massacrer son voisin à grande échelle
on arrive à le faire grâce à tous et
toutes ces histoires qu'on se raconte
on arrive à en croire des choses folles
comme par exemple dacca lui il n'y a
qu'une voie dans la jungle et on y croit
profondément
et donc notre société est devenue
extrêmement compétentes en compétition
depuis quelques dizaines d'années on a
des fac d'économie des business school
des prix nobel des équations et c'est
très bien mais maintenant il est grand
temps de redevenir compétents et de
devenir compétent en coopération en
altruisme en solidarité en fraternité et
c'est de revoir devoir est de mettre les
projecteurs sur l'autre partie du
tableau
c'est vraiment important pourquoi ça la
question pourquoi n'est pas sans savoir
que les catastrophes globales sont en
train d'avoir lieu
et je parle pas que du climat et le
problème avec notre société ses convives
dans une société d'abondance et qu'une
société d'abondance c'est pas ça le
problème c'est que ça permet l'émergence
d'une culture de l'égoïsme une culture
de la compétition
en fait la compétition et l'égoïsme
c'est un luxe de riches et du coup avec
les temps les tempêtes à venir étant
difficile qui viennent il se peut que
les pénuries ou les catastrophes soient
des problèmes en soi mais le principal
problème parce qu'on sait gérer les
pénuries depuis des centaines de
milliers d'années l'être humain il sait
gérer ça le problème c'est d'arriver
brutalement dans les pénuries avec une
culture de l'égoïsme c'est ça qui crée à
court terme des comportements égoïstes
et toxiques et dangereux et violents
c'est ça est ce que montre le vivant ce
que nous montre le vivant c'est que à
long terme ce sont les groupes les plus
coopératifs qui survivent
il tient qu'à nous de se recréer des
histoires des récits des mythes et d'y
croire et d'y aller
pour en tant qu'espèce traversé le
siècle
arrivé à traverser le siècle peut-être
au-delà en tout cas au moins jusqu'en
2084 merci de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]